صباح النور تحياتي لكم وللساده المشاهدين
نحن هنا في العاصمه الساعه الثالثه والنصف
بشكل مباشر تعرضنا لي فقط اعلان غاره جويه
لكن حتى الان يعلن عن وجود اي هجمات لكن
الاوضاع مستقره في كييف
والامور تسير بشكل سلس وان كان التركيز
الاسبوع في هذا الاسبوع على اعاده تاهيل
الملاجئ بعد الحادثه التي ادت الى مقتل
امراه وطفلتها حيث لم تستطع الوصول الى
احد الملاجئ لكن الهجوم الاكبر كان واضح
في منطقتين المنطقه الاولى هي منطقه
اوديسا هناك ثلاث ضحايا واكثر من 26 جريح
من جراء توجيه اكثر من ثلاث صواريخ سقط
منها صاروخ وايضا اتمنى مسيرات وكان هناك
مفاجاه هجوم مفاجئه على المطار العسكري في
مدينه بلطافه تضرر جزئيا ولكن تبقى الجبهه
الساخنه هي الجبهه الشرقيه التي تؤكد
القوات الاوكرانيه انها تحدث فيها ثغرات
سواء كان ضخمه او مناطق اخرى في هذه
الجبهه سيد عماد هناك تضارب في الانباء
حول الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني هل بدا فعلا
باعتقادي ان الذي بدا هو عمليات قد تكون
قد تكون جزء من الهجوم المضاد ولكنها ليست
الهجوم
الذي يعني تستعد له اوكرانيا لان هذه
الهجمات هي اصلا كانت من قبل ولكن كانت
ربما تتوقف الى حين
استعداد اكثر او وصول مزيد من الذخائر او
المعدات فبالتالي الحديث ان هناك هجوم
ابدا القضيه الابرز ان اوكرانيا لا تعول
على شن هجوم مره واحده في جبهه واحده
ومنطقه واحده هي قالت ان هذا الهجوم يستمر
في عده جبهات وبعده اشكال ولكن سيكون واضح
للجميع انه قد بدا بمعنى ان كل ما تقوم به
الان هو مجرد عمليات وليس هجوم مضاد كما
تدعي روسيا